okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is an design review
internal design review meeting that's
part of our incremental language
development series adding features too
often language we're actually at the end
of a version we pretty much wrapped up
the things for version 11.3 so this is
for future versions we're starting work
on those things we had a week's hiatus
last week because I was at the Consumer
Electronics Show um and but now we're
back and let's get going okay so first
thing is a function for converting what
is this this is for converting from one
file format to another
what's the switch my can you give a
background on this one yes this was
something that you had suggested that we
have a function to convert from one
input export file format to and it is
file format so um one example was
converting between JSON formats
okay so in other words what what this is
about is we might instead say for
example I might say export string for
example of I don't know four five six to
JSON and then I want to be able to
convert that somehow to beasts on for
instance is that the idea right they
were going from one image format to
another okay so it's basically an import
and an export yes with an intermediate
that is where the main point is to
maintain I mean
okay so okay well let's let's take that
example of from one image format to
another so picture of a fish or
something um wonderful okay so then we
would say so what's the point here we
would have this as a file for example
was is it a string of file or a byte
array
I mean I think if finally you know you
have it in a file so well so we
something like file converts and the
reason why we put it on the agenda is
that I wanted to know if you really
meant this to be file conversion or any
other conversion as well there was not a
whole lot of notes about around the
discussion you were having at the time
this has come up well do we think file
convert is an important thing to have
this has come up in previous years I
know that they tell me at some point I
think with all the file file system map
and those setup functions we should be
able to do import them export so the
conversion should be doable well yeah I
mean is it trivial and do we care and is
it undefined where we have to give a
bunch of parameters and then a bunch of
export parameters or is there some way
of doing this where we're taking charge
of keeping it as sort of lossless as
possible well it is yeah I think that
the faults are gonna be typically as
losses as possible the syntax aren't is
not going to be super trivial with file
system Maps so maybe something like if
file converter is gonna make sense house
but it's also a question of whether I
mean look that the obvious way to do
this will be a file convert with a file
name and then the possibility of a
target there and then the possibility of
that being the default is that's the
target and the non default would be
that's the that's the mapping and how
about elements do we want to get the
data out of an image and then out of it
JPEG and then export it convert it and
want to do that I think if you want to
do that then use import and export cuz
okay make it more doable
yeah the design is gonna get messy if
they want to include elements and the
question is what cases are there where
it actually makes sense I mean in other
words for example we might imagine a
file convert from an XLS file to I mean
there are cases like with audio formats
and stuff like this where people
definitely want to do conversions yes
and you know this is certainly this
thing
right get get this PNG and make it more
compressed so I'm thinking maybe even
some options for the target file format
make sense look in this case this thing
is going to output X X X X dot CSV yes
that would presumably be its default yes
okay well I think this is a reasonable
function can somebody in the
import/export team try and try and put
this together we can do this as long as
it's not you know the first version
obviously is not going to be very
efficient we might be able to look into
more optimization down the road with
specific classes of objects like for all
images try to do without of course all
you maybe do it out of core and things
like that but they're the ones where we
can't do it out of core we should try to
do that but I would I would do you know
for the I think we can just do the
simple cases for the time being and see
what it's like okay okay so such my did
you get that syntax or do or should I
send that to you or what should we do
well I took a screenshot okay all right
let's move on then okay next one is XLS
and CSV changing the default input
format to data set right for CSV you
probably have it in your build for XLS
you don't the thing is that it's going
to be backwards incompatible
[Music]
specifically Jeremy Michaelson was quite
unhappy about it on the XLS pull
requests about changing that default I'm
guessing some alpha code maybe some
serious amount of alpha code maybe
breaking after that change so well okay
so the question really is do we have it
okay is this a question
changing the default right now I mean
that's it does it work right now with
them does it doesn't it can import as a
data set the only question is how to
change the defaults exactly for CSV it
does for XLS it's gonna be wrapped up in
the next few days
CS on it is capable of sending it to a
dataset is what you're saying
yes we can already import it as day
let's say we have the data set element I
understand is that documented here yes
I'm not seeing it okay the
representation yeah
okay
so if I take this um
and I do that generically because I have
a second import yeah um okay
dandy now
okay well it looks nicer mm-hmm in cases
that you have Heather's further part of
extractions is gonna be easier honestly
it's much better
so look one thing we could do
I may regret this idea
they're two different things one is what
happens in the case where it's auto
detecting the type
look I think for this version we should
not change the default probably I think
Jeremy is probably right okay okay let's
look at it again for 12 oh okay we but
one thing we can do is soon after they
11 3 release we can change the default
in prototype builds and see what is the
overall internal impact let's do that
okay okay that brings me to another
topic about data sets that I wanted to
bring up which is the possibility of
folding of having some UX or other I
mean is is Jose here cuz can you or what
is happening with Xavier's project to
improve data set formatting and so on
he's mainly working right now in fixing
lots of bikes there are own data set and
in the process we are running and he's
learning about the type system that
formatting and he has fixed already
various things of of the formatting I
think we are more still in the face of
learning about the system and fixing
what is not working correctly rather
than improving it and adding new
features fair enough
ok so one feature that that was
discussed is the possibility of hiding
columns in data set in its default
display which i think is a good idea
doesn't work how would you choose which
ones to kind I think you would specify
in the data set formatting options which
ones to hide and then potentially they
would be closed so in other words you
would simply see a little you know a
little tick at the top for where the
columns are where there are columns but
they're closed analogous to closed cells
and then you click on it and it opens or
maybe when you hover it shows you what
they are and you click to open I see I
see I'm thinking that
in an open-air in every single column
could be a bit having that's crazy right
no I'm saying you only put it in there
when it's closed so to speak and you're
you're asking oh I see the question is
in a given column okay so two cases one
is the thing was specified in the
options to be closed upon initial
display right right and then there's the
question of opening it after it is
closed on initial display that seems
fairly uncontroversial the question then
is if something is open like one of
these can I close it exactly well I mean
we could do something we're on hover it
brings up a closer as you hover too
close to the right separator it can
bring up a closer I think that will be I
mean we need to have a UX discussion
about it
right um perhaps this is one of those
things in which you hover over the line
itself and then you move it to conclude
get a move it to one side or the other
side or something like that this line I
don't think I mean we're not moving the
line we're simply closing that what I'm
suggesting is that there's a little X
thing here that closes that group but
there closes sorry that that column
right right you could have a you know
it's a little thing that just you know
circled X or something maybe that closes
the column or maybe not really a circled
X because maybe instead it wants to be a
yeah I probably wants to be a double
down arrow thing that you click on and
it then turns into something which then
becomes a double right arrow okay to
indicate that there is a column there
but you're not seeing it
so I'm saying and then then in areas
where there is a column but you're not
seeing it you just see a bunch of little
vestigial double right arrows at the top
and you hover you click that you hover
to see what they are and you click to
open them does that make sense something
similar to this section being best we
are now happy that's correct yeah I mean
so that would
and as of earlier today we decided we
are going to have let's see in this case
right if I closed that what we've
decided is that if I open it with that
thing then I will see a and I will see
that as a closer here right if I if I do
it with these then I won't do that but
otherwise if you open with that then I
get to close with that as well okay so
should we go on here yes so I don't
think we need to share the anymore so
okay well let me just see what's coming
up with if we go through the low-hanging
business current window images what are
we starting from don't do images sorry
say that again I just know the current
window images that is but yeah okay well
if shorty is able to stick around I
think it might be nice but maybe we can
call you back I yeah I can be in the
background sure okay
all right what's next for the main thing
here we've got some letting to do yes so
there are these functions and do I need
to update here
when did you if it's yesterday it's fine
do it now just to be sure okay so with
respect to find the question of proof
and proof object where we're still
adding some more examples but and what
happened to adding the examples by the
way I assume Jonathan isn't on this call
that correct he's not he's not okay so
what happened to adding all the examples
from the no and equational logic systems
so we are adding them like share for
logic and other types of logic through
their various two pages but we don't
have the axiomatic theory function that
we were planning no I understand that I
understand but we're putting them in the
examples exactly so if I go to my gosh
stupid blog stupid stupid bug look at
this thing see that idiocy we still
could submit in that Roger no Julie no
still broken estranged so that's only
happening in your computer because I
mean that's something important you know
what's happening in my computer so I
don't know what I mean is that I haven't
seen other people complaining about this
and this is agree I we don't know what
it is it's it's something very
mysterious
it's a gremlin that got into my computer
ok so what you're saying is in here
that's a very ugly picture well yes it
just should be smaller can I make it
smaller yes we have been playing with a
with the sizes of the of the graphs and
actually there is something going on
with the default settings for the build
the build documentation and it looks
horrible in the build documentation so
okay by the way did did Charles made a
change to the the generic graph system
did he not if I say you know table of
complete graph and then I say like n and
from 3 to 10 do I know they're all the
same size wasn't there something where
we were going to change the size based
on the number of nodes well actually
maybe they're not all the same size here
I don't remember that we I mean finally
question of proof we do return the size
of the notes depending of the number of
nodes but but that's the size of the
notes not the size for the total over
the complete graph of the whole graph ok
there was a plan maybe sushma you could
chase this there was a plan to make just
like we do for images to make the
initial display size of graphs depend on
the number of nodes but now and here
okay so what am I supposed to look at
here so here we have say group theory or
further down we have surfer logic and
and yeah so here you see how the the
size of the nodes change and we have
other different shapes and different
colors so they are easier to recognize
these are not the axioms specify some
typical textbook axioms you're either
gotta say it's boolean logic or you
gotta say it's boolean you got to decide
whether it's boolean logic or boolean
algebra
I would have thought mr. Neil Zabul gets
a capital A there but I'm not passionate
about that subject I don't know whether
but it's now become a lowercase any mmm
it's so come on that but but yeah
perhaps okay so so what you're doing
here is you're giving these examples
yeah like here like this chef for logic
and we have more where you're putting
more into the section yeah exactly
okay fine so what do you think about
this case for example sorry yeah go
further than what do you think about
this last case with the bigger this big
graph here is this is the size here
reasonably nice for spine I mean it's
fine if you want to see the graph better
then come over we show the name of the
node at some point we had suggested I
mean there was a suggestion of showing
the actual expression at that moment do
you think it would be I don't know I
mean how complicated is it it it could
get quite complicated at some point but
I mean just showing critical part lemma
26 may not be not very useful
right exactly Genesis you the expression
you can trace what's going on at which
step in the preface
um well I don't know I I kind of tend to
think that we should leave this as it is
you might want to the UM for now I think
we need to get more experience with it
it's an experimental function right um
okay and we decided against having a
data repository entry with whoever's
somebody's got their camera switched on
which they probably shouldn't do so the
problem there was that we wanted to
parameterize the products and the names
of the objects exiting I know which is
why so we gave up completely on having a
that right we gave up completely on okay
anyway what was the nothing we needed to
do here yes so so in which guides do we
put this so I have some suggestions but
because this is such a special function
I wanted to check with you okay well
let's take a look here
what are we going I mean full simplify I
agree I agree with all of those do we do
we have back pointers from full simplify
yes okay so we just need to figure out
the guides the guides yes um so there is
one called logic and boolean algebra but
then I don't know where to put them in
the ones right here two equations like
manipulating equations and solving
equations well what about things
I'm not sure but let's put it in here
first
um I think we want to say here we want
to have a section there are automated
theorem proving and we want to say
don't we want to point it to things like
Gruber no basis and so on isn't it
relevant to that like the Chris Bendix
business by the way could be same with
cylindrical decomposition but you can
refer geometry but Grabner bases are
more elegant here we say some of our
logic expressions and if we shouldn't
say prove theorems here we should say
well no actually we can't say prove
theorems generate proof generate let's
see generate find symbolic
representation Baalak representations of
proofs in equation with logic okay and
then the only other thing here we have
is proof object exactly
analysis and verification yes but we
don't yet have a verification function
though we have a verification okay we
have this proof function that it returns
internally but we want to have a proof
verify which is a lot more powerful okay
all right I'm ok with that now let's go
and see what we want to do let's look at
where full simplify occurs
okay mathematics and algorithms that
might be a candidate except it's a
excised page great what's their
improving I think is that Wow well
that's um that's very much from the
quantifier elimination world I would
think yeah of course is relevant mm-hmm
it's fine because this one does quantify
this freshness as well okay so where
should we put it on this page predicates
find instance arguably it should be up
here
yeah I think so I think it's there
yes but it is sound section so yeah it
is its own section so zone here
improving manner
yeah I mean perhaps it needs as a
limiter they're all certified wants to
be on its own but it was on its own
alright but I I think it goes along with
this because full simplify is capable of
doing the exact same things it just
doesn't generate the proof object no it
offers no guarantees of anything okay I
see it closer to the polynomial algebra
subsection ok there we go let's we were
okay so equational logic
that my name sort of implies no
inequalities I don't think we want that
well it says find equational proof yeah
I saw that I'm not mean if it really is
restricted in that way then then we type
of logic that it's using that's right
exactly I mean that's you
don't be confused that that doesn't mean
that it is a okay hold on let's the four
axiom system specified specified using
equational logic okay for equational
includes
state-of-the-art capabilities for
generating full symbolic proof objects
um they're improving what we could say
theorem proving theorems from axioms
because that's what it really is
that's compared to this other stuff
which already knows what it is from
arbitrary axioms or something yes these
are axioms that can be expressed as
equations how about that exactly yep
because it's an object with the details
of the proof do you want to say proving
theorems are deriving proofs writing as
we're giving a derivation in the sense
of generating proofs from Equation
dragon gross generating groups okay
generate proofs based on arbitrary axiom
systems from from arbitrary equational
axiom systems but reasonable
okay all right let's keep going here the
heck is that
fortunately it's a defunct page um I
don't think I'll go break
transformations makes it I think in the
future ad sides and all those kinds of
things might link to this but not for
the time being the only point I wonder
about is where the graph should link to
proof object in some way does proof
object link to graph arguably it should
it's a stretch mm-hmm it could graph it
could link to graph and dataset if you
want not to dataset I think it's a
stretch to do that what's the motivation
all right forget it
what else is like proof object what
about implicit the various implicit
algebraic constructs like root objects
and things like that or is that also too
much of a stretch I think so we don't
have anything which is like step by step
if we had something to step by step it
will be a natural tool in here but fine
it's a new thing okay anything else for
these okay so we don't put it in any of
their manipulating equations
neither do getting back to what Jose
said for a moment do we have anything in
the pipeline with step by step either
within or outside of alpha yes the idea
is I mean we're talking about putting a
step by step function into the Wolfram
language that uses the Alpha code base
okay so so there will come a time when
it would make sense to put that link in
but absolutely okay all right
algebraic transformations I don't see us
putting it in here well I'll actually
hold on hold on hold on oh yeah we
should put it in here
alright okay I agree but I was talking
about the one called manipulating
equations well but this okay this is
called algebraic transformations does it
fit in here I think it sort of does yes
in the logical part yeah we can put
advancement this thing is probably no
mill reduce in it somewhere right that's
page well let's take a look yeah in the
see also sore we're not see houses in
the list of functions in the area
possibly near the apart retinal
functions are polynomial expressions I
have no idea I mean it's probably
underneath there should I look yeah what
is it what is the one you're looking for
polynomial reduce that is such a mess
that whole polynomial mod versus
polynomial reduced Festus all these
other things I've never understood that
stuff now withstanding all right it's
another problem for another day all
right okay so what did you have one
called manipulating equations
manipulating equations yes this has the
new add sides and related not yet will
have Roger was gonna do that and if he
doesn't do it then I'll do it right so I
wanted to find some guide page that
focuses on the equation part not ended
not on the proof part okay what what do
we say here we connected here
same thing find proofs from equation
equation elections well okay we could
have a things here saying I don't see
this I'm sorry I think this is a much
more obscure complicated thing I really
don't see this this is a fairly
elementary page I mean this page
absolutely needs the the whole know ad
sides business on it okay okay alright
let's wrap these up hey I wanted to make
one change in the function function page
I was going to do this let's just move
I'm fed up with people oh okay
does said has attributes there okay that
was changed good yes so what we
discussed recently I think here is the
notation now in the first document that
was the thing that was in there yes so
being able to because if you want to use
attributes in the third argument and you
don't have a named variable you have to
use null in the first argument and I
think that was the thing okay so that's
the last time so so that's the thing
yeah let okay fine okay scale does the
second argument for random sample we
have to authenticate in dialogue jasmine
you
you
boy is this it has it got back pointers
from all of these yeah I don't see it
there okay I'll ask you to do that well
whose no but I mean wait a minute where
do we want to put this in guide pages no
I understand but here I have to bow out
it's okay that's fine I don't think
you're important for this particular
thing this is probably the very first
thing
you
so it once
there
you
then it wants to go in
it's not for permissions right it's an
alternative to permissions key
you
it's relevant for encrypt
is that right you can use it for encrypt
is that true yes you can put it in the
first argument of encrypt right
boy that's going to
stuffin it
you
you
okay and Oh field masked
boy that better see
show it
you
you
um
okay did we put it in sorry did I just
put it in encrypt
yes
okay permission
that probability and
you
okay
need to put it in secured authentication
key is a much more obscure creature
yeah I don't think it should go in there
it's kind of a complicated thing and by
the time you're using a secure
authentication key you're not using this
other stuff okay so let's go here
you
there is one page called dialogue above
six and there's one called
authentication control here Wow why is
that so future iced this needs to be
checked into we need to figure out why
that's still future iced okay that
doesn't seem right to me um and this
should be pointing to that
authentication control stuff okay um
this is okay let's go here hmm okay so
that goes there but then we're also
going to want I think this is a bit of a
messy thing I think we're going to need
a little bit more work on this I
understand
that this page needs to get modified for
secure authentication key as well okay
let's get a separate meeting set up for
this yep there's some messiness here and
can you find out what happened to this
authentication control page yes I can do
that okay
okay good all right let's look at this
scale - the second argument from random
sample thing ready to do that yep or not
he's not here but the idea seemed seems
simple so this looks to me this looks
like it makes some sort of relative take
spec yes I agree and that's an
interesting question whether that could
actually be it takes back as well so if
I could say take range of a hundred
scale the 0.5 that's sort of interesting
all this it's gonna fail right now but
that's interesting so this requires that
if we know the least the total list and
the order of course we need to have an
order then we can just take 50% yes I
think that's interesting what are the
other cases where we might have this
well there are many functions that say
take only n objects which in a sense is
I take aspects that reduce take a spec
yes
why did this open by the way with the
details open that's wrong yeah I mean
things like string take saying 50% there
that will be useful I
things that have a takes back could use
this actually it's a cool idea okay well
I think it needs a bit more of
exploration just to make sure that we
are not forgetting something important
but yeah right but it's gonna have to
round and things like this right exactly
probably we don't want run into zero and
things like that but yeah yeah that's an
interesting question what does it do if
it's out of range bla bla bla I mean it
it yeah you know scaled of to probably
should just give everything yeah I never
or or everything it's it's like when we
say infinity yeah I mean it is a
slightly slippery slope because we could
imagine part specifications or span
specifications with scaled in them well
that's why I wanted to focus on take a
speck
I think this is take not part because
part I mean what is a relative position
relative size or length feels better
yeah I agree I agree
alright let's just for the sake of
getting somewhere I'm supposed to go to
something soon but let's let's for the
sake of getting somewhere let's just
take a little look at so what was the
first item that I was supposed to look
at here print window image find what
current in window image
did we did we cover oh I wanted to did
we talk about
delete outliers yeah I was I'm supposed
to send that do what I do okay okay
doing I wanted to talk about which
probably isn't for this group is
external value so that has to do with um
for things where where you know for like
this case okay if we're doing you know
we're running around and piece of Python
code what I would like to be able to do
is to be able to say for this session
right so that particular thing is an
external session that was started and
I'm making sense so I think if I say
external sessions I will see that there
is an external session there see what
I'm saying yeah so I would like to be
able to define an external value which
is set inside that external session so I
can refer to the external value inside
the external session you see what I'm
saying I see so the first argument is
that externalization objects do have
their that is correct
yes and the second argument is the name
of that variable in the external session
so that then allows me to string
together different pieces of this
external session but it allows me to
interrogate variables that were set in
the external session there's probably
not the right group to talk about this I
think that's probably something for I
think Dorian is going to take over this
particular code base if I'm not mistaken
it's somewhere between Garrett and
Dorian decision or if you could try and
you know chase that down there okay okay
now what am I looking for I'm looking
for
by the way how is around doing these
days I need to go back to it after I
mean it would be one of my main projects
after after we released lo three okay
okay current window images so I mean if
I say current and we have do we have
current window image we have got a
notebook image which is another thing
but we don't have current window image
and I wanted to check if this is just a
change of name that we had no no no this
would be something different this is a
thing where you so current notebook
image fine okay so this would be and I
don't know if this is doable this would
be just like we have system processes so
there is a tree of Windows as displayed
on the screen and the question is can we
pick up images from all the windows
displayed on the screen okay and what's
the meaning of current how do we refers
to a current window well I mean current
as in this is the image of the window as
it is right now like here we can see
current notebook image shows that actual
cell evaluating when the screen image
was taken yes but Karen that would make
sense because we are evaluating this in
a notebook but if the window is some
sort of browser window or whatever no no
but I'm saying current window images is
just saying given your operating system
right given the windows system just get
an image of every single window as it
currently is configured oh I see I see I
see so current means no no no DS window
I think that is correct just like
current image means the image taken by
your camera right now I see I see
I thought the current notebook is this
not look
I supposed to know I understand the
current modifies the image not the
notebook right okay um this is a
question really for I guess ooh who
would be doing this maybe Garrett again
I'm not sure I don't know how these
things were done originally I don't know
this is using the robot tools technology
stack from QA all of these current image
although these window image things I
believe so I guess a scar node who
should now be dealing with that okay
all right the next try I wanted to talk
about was this faded form function which
I feel quite strongly about have we
talked about that at a different time
that's the thing where we keep on using
it for blogs and things a thing where
we're basically showing a result so
let's say I have short of range of a
thousand comma five or something right
that's just cutting it off that is so
freaking ugly
that is so version one ish I mean we
really should make this some kind of
graphical thing at the very least we
should make that graphical maybe we need
rather than using those silly gorilla
maze I mean at the very least let's
because this was built at a time when
this was basically for terminal output
okay but so the idea of faded form is
that we're literally taking the bitmap
of this thing and we're fading it beyond
a certain number of lines am i making
sense and it would be a I mean I suppose
we could kind of have a test version of
it that's just based on rasterize
because we already have this
functionality in and I'm gonna have to
go in a second unfortunately we already
have this functionality in that we use
for creating things for blogs Jeremy
Davis has this okay so chase that down
with Jeremy find out what he has okay
let's let's see whether so is this like
a
Jeremy Davis me sprintin kind of thing I
don't know I don't know because it
depends I I think it might be you know
we may have to do it with much
processing it may be that there is no
you know I mean ultimately it should be
a front-end display option but it may be
that as a practical matter it's not
obvious okay once you have the faded
form it is not obvious what should
happen if you select inside it
I'm making sense well that's really the
question so okay we should bring this
back for the purpose of what kinds of
fading we added a few of these framing
effects to image effect 11 - really so I
think that torn paper was another one
faded sides I think by default it fades
all the sides that last what do you know
framing effect well I'm not beautiful
okay
well that's nice yeah I mean this is
exactly what we want the question is
whether
I mean but this is not really saying can
I just use image effects to fade
something probably not because I you
know what I want is to actually cut it
off at a certain point it's got several
parameters that are needed like you know
basically for fading you know probably
in a perfect world faded form will
produce something that actually has some
kind of opener or pulldown shade
pulldown type thing that allows me to
unfaded if I want to mm-hmm um all right
we better wrap it up here um and to be
continued thank you may all soon bye-bye